stack armadilha já montada ou 321 bora
ai meu deus o tac brasil-petrobras solta
que quer falar andar que sejam muito bem
vindos anuais um vídeo e os trabalhos
aqui em um dos vídeos mais perigosa
administração não é mas faz com que os
pessoal nós vamos testar a resistência
do nosso iphone né armadilha de urso
está aqui armadilha já montada
das duas uma ou os últimos jogos fiz um
bom trabalho é fã vai existir o wifi vai
ser completamente aniquilado destruído
deste poder saber que com a nossa
modelos agora uma das duas é cometer o
que vai acontecer só no nome das
armadilhas do som muito melhor que serve
precisamente para pássaros na época o
mar - não era uma armadilha e lembranças
para 0 11% gente só está gravado aqui e
voz misteriosa como sempre
palmas para as misteriosas só agora é
que nós vamos estar aqui muita coisa uma
banana em porto xavier linha um pino uma
égua mostra nossa bebida energética
favorita já agora mostra se quiserem
outro sinal de que o canal tornam tá tão
à vontade eu sei mas 500 gel de barbear
e mais importante vamos fazer um teste
de resistência do nosso iphone
meu deus o que será que vai acontecer eu
acho que não vai existir acho que sim
o pessoal está aqui não é o iphone só
quer eu coloquei aqui esta carrinha para
a câmera isto é o elefante x s max mas
eu coloquei que esta equipe nick wirth
também para perceber o iphone
cosmeticamente né atenção não é o iphone
e smartphones já não está a funcionar
direito por isso é que eu vou fazer aqui
o texto aqui eu nunca vi ele fazer isso
meu iphone atual nunca porque o pai
completamente novo e isso é um
desperdício né então vamos estar aqui
com este inclusive eu tenho aqui uma
capinha também protetor é uma é uma
película de vidro temperado acho que é
isso então pode ser que ela está melhor
mas vamos ver isso ela acompanhe o vídeo
até o fim porque vai ser em seis anos
certamente vai ser para lá só para vocês
perceberem que o mecanismo é muito fácil
é que a cantora tem um sistema contei
aqui este centro e tudo que entrar aqui
no maio este
os partidos pois fez on e em tal um
objeto que estava indo embora lá estar
aqui com a caneta 321 ou uma caneta no
futuro nada só os grandes da minha mão e
vocês repararam que precisa imenso fosse
para ativar a armadilha é porque está
mesmo com um amigo quando só quando
troca ali só quando coelho o rato toca
aí é que o flash e prende a pata
meu deus óbvio que vou usar isso para um
animal nega saber usar aqui em tese não
existe estudo sucre daquele tempo ou é
ter parte o canudo que está por dentro
eu fui atingida com nas canetas idle sim
meu deus como nós esperam ver essa
medida tem muita força agora temos que
montar outra vez então é preciso muita
força pra montar e não se conseguiu nada
se ouviu ajude a sair
é isso ai sim sim ok pessoal próxima
coisa que vamos conquistar então vai ser
o tupi não vamos ver seu conselho porque
o tupi online nessa por uma caneta é
feita quase que com certeza vai procurar
um pino a pino você vai tentar burlar
3215 lado 321 ópera isso ficou entalado
tirá lo aqui
o leis mas fez uma marca bem grande e
achou no maio
olha aqui
vai se chamar assim a parte fácil da
minha cozinha da orelha não vou por néné
ok se muda para outra mesmo agora lançou
próxima coisa banana e açaí banana e 29
com certeza
ok vamos tentar arrancar a caixa é o
primeiro que acontece porque acho que
vai dar uma assistência estrela não
quero isso até então vamos lá para se
rever silva tiago 321 culpa de cada
prefeito prefeitinho banana outra vez
nós já fizemos um vídeo integra como
bananinha tomá lá é o prêmio um bom
teste às misteriosas é que o texto do
acordo com a vontade aqui os materiais
todos os quarto e assim eu já tenho uma
toalha preparada que só dá muita sujeira
ou não em péssima idéia agora sim mas o
verso um curso e para lá em 321
condicionada por aí vamos tentar outra
vez porque eu acho que não sou time
mostra portanto vou tentar encaixar
vamos lá tentar outra de três gols
o zoom óptico lá ficou a empresa o
serviço em quinto
só para vocês terem noção da força olha
lá 500 mililitros meio mito é
literalmente meio litro aqui
sustentado por esta armadilha é muito
peso ainda não é bom como vocês puderam
ver quem é este texto foi monstruoso
dava uma boa decoração pro teto onde
pensa em si mas para lá então a próxima
coisa que vamos usar eu acho que desta
vez fora mas estamos aqui novamente e
resistente que relata de forma de
barbear vamos ver o que acontece se
explodir mas sim o início já o bbva
então agora vai testar isso tudo é blá
321 vai aprendeu o hotel prendeu muita
força o coração essa também pode ser uma
decoração é verdade que a nossa vida e
tecnicamente está muito bem pensado é
porque existe uma armadilha para um
animal para um coelho ou assim vocês não
querem concorrer e fuja então isso tem
que prender empatar mas o coelho precisa
continuar muito em si ela cotação lata
quer dizer também executar o uso do
coelho e 14 com três patas ainda pode
fugir não não não é verdade
enquanto com três faltas ainda faz tipo
vai só assim guardo nenhum
agora a busca dos ter sido muito forte
tem que instalar até o uso o que vamos
ver em que marcas exatamente ontem que
mais amou delas nada mais toque todo aí
bala só o próximo objeto que voltar vai
ser material escolar uma simples régua
esta sim acho que vai quebrar esta marca
chegou da escola materials claro verso
10 marido urso comentem o que vocês
acham que eu vou buscar um segundo 12
podem comentar o assunto vai quebrar o
assunto não 34 55 segundos que o tempo
para lá estar
entrei esso em 2000 eo não aconteceu
nada
em carta à aiea intacta o grupo é isso
meu ela tá assim eu ia dizer que ela
estava muito frágil lhe que era só um
toque por dia e não foi isso que
aconteceu
então é mais caro vendido funciona
portanto quem come do enriquecimento e
que a arma dele e ganhar aqui neste
mundo s do iphone também o que você acha
que vai ganhar um iphone ou ipad do
curso podem já começar a comentar
a próxima coisa que eu vou usar só um
professor diz que vai na ue china e está
um porta chaves que tem uma coisa
especial por dentro de si uma jima do
estranha é mais claro nem henrique então
vamos ver se na armadilha da conta de
explodir o pequi dentro eu vou ficar e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer para lá ok
vamos lá ver se consigo arrumar isso
sozinho não é possível fazer muita força
calma calma eu vou tentar voltar mesmo a
misteriosa isso mesmo se acontecer
alguma coisa o que quer que aconteça
continuar a filmar é isso mesmo vai
destruir a nossa galinha ou ela vai
ficar sem internet e sem cabeça ou
captar a galinha
está-se muito macabro pessoal para este
que vai ser um evento macabro do ano que
vocês vão ver este ano pelo segundo ano
é porque este ano até lá três do zoom
o elenco aqui coitadinha da lei e
trancado olha aí ficou agarrada pelos
cabelos
gravo o nosso foco continua intacto e
ficou viva sempre captar sem nada muito
é incrível temos aqui então o nosso
iphone x s max cometem desde já quem vai
ganhar esta batalha seu iphone se acham
que o ecrã vai quebrar os tirar nossa
ilha de deus e atenção pra fazer que
esse teste porque não quer arriscar
muito nós vamos ter que fazer com o
android que eu tinha aqui já há algum
tempo eu acho que é normal que theo já
não usados tanto tempo eu usei só para
alguns testes só prejudicará algumas
coisinhas que não tem uma nova com pouca
candidato foi bem mais barato portanto
em princípio vai curar mas se não
quebrar o que alguém já te dizer que
algumas pressa para o iphone agora se
acontecer o contrário eu vou respeitar
muito os tokio hotel por si só que eu
não procurarei pois o iphone que o
horário
eu vou respeitar nenhum texto ao cartel
muito benéfico jogos na arena
josé o gênio é próprio texto android na
nossa ilha do sul
em seu primeiro texto do iphone 3 2 1
com a brawn não digo que não quebrou
dizem que não quebrou o pé quebrado está
onde mostro existiu a vinho só quebrou a
cni aponta
eu espero que isso não aconteça a nossa
fome eu espero mesmo que aconteceu na
nossa forma e vou ficar muito triste é
que minha preocupação é qual até aqui
para frente tem um monitor claro mas por
trás
é plástico é puramente costa e e aqui
não é forma que você estava em vidro a
frente e vidros traz portanto mesmo que
não importa a frente poderá partir atrás
comentei já o que vocês acham que eu vou
montar criar uma liga para lá então
pessoal iphone versus armadilha de urso
em 321 bora está quebrada há um fato
grave e vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver o
que o quadro tem duas câmeras eu quase
se tem das câmeras
ok eu vou cumprir meu deus acho que
quebrou a frente
ok atrás e não conseguiu nada está
intacto não condicionada agora à frente
olha que um arquiteto que aconteceu
quebrou que ensina
mesmo que só está na hora de eu vou
ficar aqui olha a próxima à ilha próxima
à próxima vamos confirmar de novo vamos
terminar o vídeo por equipe só sei que
vocês têm um estado chave enquanto o
nosso mel é que aqui em baixo neste dia
também para laptops facilmente e não
digam nada envie o link não digam que eu
só mas nenhum link vamos ver a reação de
rock e depois minhas respostas por de
emaús história vá para o instagram eu
quero ver o que é que os movimentos
responderam e voltar lá e também os
comentários mais originais e que no meu
e do butantã comentar alguma coisa
engraçada eu vou deixar o aqui pra vocês
que vou responder a alguns comentários
portanto interajam pessoal temos aqui
uma comunidade incrível é agora tudo
está bem e podia portanto vamos
aproveitar o máximo que só fiquem vai
até a próxima